unterwegs in malaysia in der nähe der
hauptstadt kuala lumpur tonnenweise
direkt aus der ersten welt verabredung
mit einer umweltaktivisten vor leib
hängen zeigt uns eine illegale müllkippe
mitten in der peilen mittel
hier liegt auch abfall aus deutschland
zum beispiel verpackungen von pizza käse
kochschinken gummibärchen kartoffel
taschen müll händler versuchten pur leib
hang einzuschüchtern erfolglos wenn wir
nichts unternehmen würden wir doch eh
sterben sagt sie uns weil die umwelt so
verschmutzt sein
aber wieso landet deutscher müll in
malaysia thailand indonesien sind
inzwischen die sortieranlagen für europa
oder für die usa das heißt der track
team wir hier nicht gebrauchen können
geht nach malaysia und wird dort
sortiert das was man noch verwenden kann
wird abgetrennt wird gereinigt und wird
dort dann wieder für neue
plastikprodukte genutzt das scheint sich
zu lohnen finanziell sonst würde es
nicht passieren aber der rest der dort
aussortiert wird und nicht gebraucht
werden kann er bleibt eben auf teilweise
unkontrollierten deponien liegen in
deutschland kommen verpackungen in die
gelbe tonne die entsorger suchen sich
den plastik heraus den sie einfach
recyceln können der muss sauber sein und
sortenrein beschichtete verpackungen
bereiten probleme
was den deutschen bisher zu aufwendig
ist und zu teuer
er wird verbrannt oder geht in
billiglohnländer wie in südostasien
wenn malaysia sind die lohnkosten
deutlich niedriger da lohnt es sich viel
eher den abfall noch mal manuell
auseinander zu glauben etiketten aus
folien auszuschneiden tatsächlich von
hand und dann am ende das material das
man gut recyceln kann für teuer geld
weiter zu verkaufen und was passiert mit
dem anderen genau das ist genau der
punkt in deutschland würde der
sehr gut dokumentiert am ende
höchstwahrscheinlich verbrannt was damit
dann in malaysia passiert ist glaube ich
genau die quelle des problems eigentlich
haben die händler dafür bezahlt dass
verpackungen ordnungsgemäß entsorgt
werden das duale system das größte der
grüne punkt teilt uns mit seiner
altkunststoffe landeten weltweit
ausschließlich per zertifizierten
abnehmern wie plastikmüll trotzdem noch
malaysia kommen kann erklärt das
unternehmen nicht erst vor wenigen
monaten entdeckte die
umweltschutzorganisation greenpeace 45
solcher illegalen kippen
sie fand auch verpackungen aus
deutschland zum beispiel von aldi nord
hof börger ziegenkäse
auch der discounter kann sich das auf
nachfrage nicht erklären wird dass
plastik verbrannt entstehen giftige gase
eine gefahr für die anwohner
mein ältester sohn ist 13 jahre alt und
hatte probleme mit den augen
sie waren immer gereizt beide augen
waren entzündet und trennten
im krankenhaus konnten sie keinen grund
dafür finden meine tochter hustet auch
immer ich habe nur gemerkt dass es
komisch riecht aber ich wusste nicht
warum und bei meinen beiden kindern war
immer die luftröhre entzündet wann immer
sie den rauch eingeatmet haben der beim
verbrennen von müll entsteht mussten sie
einen spezialisten aufsuchen und
brauchten einen inhalator einige
kilometer weiter eine garnelen form die
zucht teiche voller abfall
niemand hier kann ausschließen dass
plastikteile in die nahrungskette
gelangen
die schwermetall werte im wasser sind
stark erhöht eine mögliche folge der
plastik brände
als wir vor einigen wochen vor ort sind
zeigt man uns stolz eine legale plastik
recyclinganlage was abenteuerlich
aussieht sei nicht das problem erklären
uns die behörden denn hier würde
angeblich ordnungsgemäß recycelt dann
eine razzia extra für die kamera die
betreiber dieser fabrik sind längst
ausgeflogen
zurück bleibt der mühle für den seien
nun die vermieter zuständig erklärt uns
der zuständige minister wie auch in
dieser fabrik sie wurde schon vor
monaten geschlossen
sehen sie die gefahr dass illegale
fabriken einfach woanders wieder
aufmachen kann schon sein aber da können
wir nichts machen dafür sind wir nicht
zuständig nach malawischem recht können
wir auf der städtischen und landesebene
nur gegen die vermieter aktiv werden
gegen die illegalen fabrik betreiber
dürfen wir nicht vorgehen
auf der illegalen müllkippe finden wir
reichlich netze für zwiebeln edeka mit
perlen die schiere menge legt die netze
kommen nicht aus dem gelben sack dem
dualen system sondern wurden vermutlich
direkt vom produzenten entsorgt
gewerbemüll wie kann der nach malaysia
edeka erklärt uns der lieferant der
perlen sitze im niederländischen quote
brück der habe edeka versichert kein
verpackungsmaterial abgegeben zu haben
der lieferant beziehe die netze von
einem unternehmen in graphen sande und
das wiederum lasse die zwiebel netze im
italienischen cesenatico zieren der nun
habe ein bisschen dienstleister in
valletta und der wolle alle
aussortierten verpackungsmaterialien mit
markenlogo ordnungsgemäß zerkleinert
haben kurzum keiner kann erklären wie
die netze nach malaysia kam die illegale
abfall verschiebung betrifft mehrere
länder
sie hat eine internationale dimension
hinter dem illegalen abfalltransport von
einem land und ein anderes stecken
verschiedene gruppen der organisierten
kriminalität
es ist ein krimineller trend der hierauf
kommt das bundesumweltministerium
fordert nun konsequenzen
wir in deutschland müssen stärker zu
sehen dass eben erkennbar mit dem sinn
es illegal zu exportieren
ein solcher will nicht ins ausland
verbracht wird wollen deshalb werden wir
mit ländern wie malaysia jetzt auch vom
bund auf dem bundesumweltministerium aus
in kontakt treten um hier die
zusammenarbeit zu versterben müll
exporte können in die deutschen
recyclingquoten eingerechnet werden auch
dann wenn sie gesetzeswidrig deponiert
werden
damit ist völlig unklar ob tatsächlich
wie die industrie behauptet 50 prozent
der deutschen verpackungen recycelt
werden
die industrievereinigung
kunststoffverpackungen sie darin erst
einmal kein problem
wir wissen sehr wohl dass wenn sie
möchten dass das oft die deutschen
recyclingquoten angerechnet wird dann
muss es auch nach deutschen standards
passieren dann gibt sie was ist das in
ordnung dass das in die recyclingquote
einfließt wenn es nach ihm geht weil sie
können das ja gar nicht nachprüfen
ja es ist dann in ordnung wenn es
tatsächlich recycelt wird
und wenn entsprechende auditierung
stattfinden wenn das kontrolliert wird
das soll so sein wie vermutlich und so
oft im leben
wird es aber auch stellen geben an denen
man einfach noch einmal nachschauen was
wo passiert das nicht passiert illegales
wo wird kriminell gehandelt
da muss natürlich schon entsprechend der
finger drauf gelegt werden doch das
passiert offenbar nicht ausreichend
sonst würde nicht deutscher abfall in
malaysia und anderswo in südostasien
liegen
zwar gilt in deutschland seit beginn des
jahres ein neues verpackungs gesetz der
handel muss nun melden wie viel plastik
im umlauf ist
was aber mit den einzelnen verpackungen
genau passiert lässt sich nach wie vor
nicht zurückverfolgen
wenn wir nicht wollen dass unser abfall
irgendwo in der welt an einem strand
oder am see landet dann brauchen wir ein
system wo er genau weiß der
joghurtbecher der da in malaysia am
strand gelegt wurde von genau diesen
hersteller in deutschland den verkehr
über genau der hersteller hat dann auch
dafür zu sorgen dass der dahinten
zumindest wieder anständig gesammelt und
verwertet wird
es braucht sehr strenge regeln und es
braucht vor allen dingen auch wirklich
maßnahmen die die industrie dazu bringt
weniger plastik zu produzieren das heißt
steuererleichterung für
wiederverwendbare reparierbaren produkte
ich glaube das wäre während guter weg so
lange weiter massenhaft plastik nach
asien exportiert wird hat man hier in
malaysia ganz praktische sorgen wohin
mit dem müll der bislang hier landete
[Musik]
haben sie eine nachricht an die länder
deren müll herumliegt bitte nehmt euren
müll zurück wir sind hier nicht eure
deponie
[Musik]